try them out well show the community is
in mourning after a trans terrorist
walked into a Christian School and
murdered six people here in Nashville
including uh three children the media is
playing all of their expected games even
finding a way to blame conservatives for
this tragedy but we'll try to get to the
heart of the matter today I have a lot
to say about this and we'll talk about
it all today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
you've heard about the horrific shooting
at the Covenant School here in Nashville
yesterday a tragedy that has hit our
community incredibly hard six victims
three staff members at the school were
killed and three children who were all
nine years old and this one I can say
lands close to home for me literally
close to home in the sense that Covenant
is just a few miles from the studio and
not far from where I live and because I
know people whose children attend that
school and um
well I know people whose children attend
that school and I can't fathom what the
families of those murdered children are
going through what it must be like to
have woken up this morning if you slept
at all knowing that you will face this
day and all remaining days without your
precious child it is unfathomable
but there are yet more families today
who are forced to experience a form of
suffering that the rest of us can't even
imagine
there's a lot that needs to be said
about this but let's start with the
basic facts as we understand them today
so on Monday morning Audrey Hale 28 year
old female who identified as transgender
shot through a locked side entrance of
the school building made her way to the
second floor and opened fire there were
no school resource officers the campus
had no armed security of any kind
apparently
police responded to the scene within
about 15 minutes had killed the suspect
and uh sent her to hell where she will
stay forever as she deserves but not
before six people were slaughtered
including the three children one of
those children nine-year-old Haley
Scruggs was the daughter of Chad Scruggs
who's the pastor of the Covenant Church
now that was unspeakable evil that
entered the school on Monday but it was
met with bravery and heroism which we
should acknowledge Nashville police
thankfully did not follow in the
footsteps of the cops in Uvaldi
um instead they they ran to the sound of
the gunfire and the the in fact just
this morning the uh body cam footage was
released and we can see this happening
they go into that school they go right
to where they hear the gunfire head
first into the danger and uh they kill
the monster meanwhile from what I've
heard there were many other scenes of
teachers and staff members rushing to
protect their students incredible
courage rising up against the evil yet
the evil made its Mark in the most
devastating of ways
as for the motive the police
to this point as I'm speaking right now
haven't said very much but they have
confirmed that the shooter identified as
trans and they indicated rather strongly
I think that her trans identification
had something to do with motivating the
crime here's the Nashville police chief
listen
our investigations tell us that she was
a former student at the school I don't
know what grade she's attended or grades
but we do uh affirmly believe she was
the student there so
she does
I didn't identify as transgender yes and
no motive at this point uh anything
discovered in the apartment or house no
we have a Manifesto we have some
writings that we're going over that
pertain to this day the actual incident
we have a map drawn out of how this was
all going to take place there's right
now a theory of that's that we may be
able to talk about later but it's not
confirmed and so we'll we'll put that
out as soon as we can and she is there
any reason to believe that how she
identifies
I'm sorry I'm not someone with Michael I
didn't hear you say that again sir is
there any reason to believe that how she
identifies is has any motive for
targeting the school
uh we can give you that at a later time
there is uh some Theory to that we're
investigating all the leads and once we
know exactly we will let you know so
what's this a targeted attack
it was
so the shooter identified as trans she
had a Manifesto it was a targeted attack
against the Christian School and there
is He suggests reason to believe that
her self-identification played a role in
the attack itself
now these details have created confusion
in the corporate media with some Outlets
simply deciding for the first time in
years and entirely for political reasons
here to ignore Transit identification
and stick with the biologically
appropriate pronouns in this case in
this case only
while other outlets have issued
corrections to ensure that their pronoun
usage is compliant USA Today tweeted uh
yesterday afternoon quote police on
Monday afternoon said that the shooter
was a transgender man officials had
initially misidentified the gender of
the shooter
the New York Times had a similar
clarification there was confusion later
on Monday about the gender identity of
the assailant to the National Shooting
officials had used she and her to refer
to the suspect to according to a social
media post and a LinkedIn profile
appeared to identify as a man in recent
months
so in both cases both cases basically
chastising the police for misgendering
uh this despicable ghoulish monster
but this is a subject that the left
would rather not discuss at all they'd
prefer to skip over the questions of the
shooter's identity and motivation and
keep the whole discussion focused on
guns that's where the White House took
the issue right away as we expect and
without any hesitation at all listen
we must do more and he wants Congress to
act because enough is enough
in his State of the Union the president
called on Congress to do something
to stop the epidemic of gun violence
tearing families apart tearing
communities apart
how many more children have have to be
murdered
before republicans in Congress will step
up and act to pass the assault weapons
ban
to close loopholes in our background in
our in our background check system
or to require the safe storage of guns
we need to do something
yes it's all the Republicans fault when
a trans person shoots up a Christian
School you know the only people to blame
are Republicans obviously Joe Biden had
a similar message okay now let's go over
a few details here a few points
first of all
this is not about guns
and these damned frauds know damn well
that it's not about guns
and they know that because guns have
existed for hundreds of years the
firearms that they erroneously refer to
as assault weapons have been around for
decades
and yet we all seem to agree that only
in recent years have these sorts of mass
shootings and in particular school
shootings school shootings seem to have
become commonplace
um if guns were the cause of the problem
then there's no particular reason why
mass shootings should be more common now
than they were 60 years ago or even 100
years ago
but however you measure mass shootings
into whatever degree they've increased
over time the real question the big
question
the question that actually matters right
now is why
why do people want to commit these acts
what drives it what motivates it
if you could take away all the guns snap
your fingers and make them disappear or
float into space
still you would be left with a country
infested with homicidal sociopaths who
don't value human life
that is not a safe place to be no matter
what weapons are available or not
available so why guns are the tools that
many of these murderers use but why do
they commit the murders in the first
place the vast majority of people own
who own guns and will own them for their
entire lives without ever murdering
anyone I own guns I've never murdered
anybody and never will why do they these
people do it okay why that that's what
matters
if we were going to skip over the why
question and discuss only how to
mitigate the existing risk
then that conversation should revolve
first and foremost around security the
Covenant School again had no armed
security on campus it was a soft target
that is an easily accessible and
unsecured location with large numbers of
unarmed people most of whom happen to be
children
every day millions of parents send their
children off to soft targets
and The Killers choose them as targets
precisely for this reason in fact the
police chief said as much in the press
conference yesterday listen
the only school that was targeted it was
the only school that was targeted there
was another location that was mentioned
but because of a threat assessment by
the suspect too much security they
decided not to in that area was here in
Nashville so we're continuing with that
investigation as well
so did you get that she wanted to go
somewhere else but decided not to
because they had security
so so then she went to the place without
any this is not a difficult equation
it's not hard to figure out every school
should have armed security there is
absolutely no rational argument against
it no sane decent person can possibly
object to our children being protected
the way the way we protect our money in
Banks okay nobody objects having armed
security in a bank
or the way we protect our politicians
and the buildings where they work
our children deserve at least the same
amount of security as we give to our
money and our politicians and I would
say quite a bit more in fact
you would have to be a psychopath to
disagree I mean it is that simple
but this still does not address the
underlying question which is again the
why
so let's talk about that
and in this case we cannot ignore the
killer self-identification in fact this
is only the latest in a string of mass
shootings committed by someone from this
identity group the Colorado Springs Mass
shooter identifies as non-binary the
shooter at a Denver charter school in
2019 identified as trans a mass shooter
shot seven people at a warehouse in
Aberdeen Maryland the year before that
identified as trans
and these are not isolated incidents
these are not random uh bursts of
violence from an otherwise peaceful
group
not remotely
in fact this happened this latest
shooting happened during a week when
trans activists have been calling for
quote a trans day of Vengeance with at
least one suggesting that the day of
engine should happen outside of the
studio where I'm currently sitting
as I have tried to warn for a long time
radical far-left trans activism is a
hateful violent movement
it is more hateful and more violent than
any other movement in memory
and I know that okay I know that
not just because they March you know in
their in their in their rallies holding
banners telling their opponents to kill
themselves and making other explicit
violent threats this is at like every
trans rally you you go to you're going
to see this
though that is what they do and that's
part of the issue
it's not just that
and it's not just because they were on
Twitter yesterday justifying the
shooting on the basis that in the words
of one trans activist oppressed
minorities are striking back
striking back by killing children
but it's not just that I know it also
because I've lived through it okay my
family has lived through it we live we
live through it every day I I haven't
experienced even a fraction of what
these families at the Covenant School
are suffering through yet I've seen
enough firsthand to know
that these people will do and say
anything
to those they consider their enemies
they will do anything to intimidate and
silence you
they will dox you they will blackmail
you they will threaten you
they will call for violence against you
they will threaten your family they will
threaten your children
they will harass you
they will commit violence against you
this is how the movement operates
and anyone who's taken a serious stand
against it and attracted its ire knows
that
now in this divided culture you're
guaranteed to get intense pushback if
you take you know any position well any
correct position any truthful position
anyway on any topic but the pushback on
the trans topic it is just unlike
anything else it just is it's not just
pushback it is a tidal wave of
bloodthirsty rage
from people who deeply and truly want
you dead and they want your family dead
they will tell you that if you ask them
or even if you don't
now what makes this situation so
dangerous is that
aside from the obvious
is that this thirst for vengeance this
rage is explicitly encouraged by our
institutions
you can find many media articles just
like this one from Teen Vogue calling
for us to quote stop policing trans rage
in other words let them act out as
violently as they want because they're
entitled to
from the very top echelons of our
society from the most powerful people
and institutions we are told that those
who oppose gender ideology those who
wish to protect children from being
brainwashed into the cult protect
children from being abused and mutilated
and castrated are engaging in genocide
this is the language from again this is
not the fringes of the movement where we
hear this kind of language
it's very much in the mainstream
and when you point
to someone who's a Critic of gender
ideology and you say they're committing
genocide
that is nothing less than an open and
direct invitation to commit violent acts
against that person
in an invitation to do exactly what was
done yesterday
you know the trans activists are assured
that somehow those who disagree with
them are a threat to their very lives
just by disagreeing
that those who don't do not affirm their
self-identity are engaging in violence
simply by not affirming
that the refusal to affirm is
essentially an act of murder okay
because you're murdering Me by not
affirming my self-identity because my
self-identity is the only identity that
matters and if you make me question my
self-identity then you're then you are
basically killing me that's the logic
and it is a logic
that gives a green light to carry out
atrocities it is intended to do that
that is how it is intended
let's stop beating around the bush and
pretending otherwise
this is what they want
every time someone someone in the media
someone in DC anyone else points at
Christians at conservatives at any of us
and says they want genocide
what they're really saying is deal with
them shut them down silence them take
them out
[Music]
that's how the words are interpreted
because how else could they be
interpreted after all if somebody was
really carrying out a genocide then
violence would be the appropriate
response
but it's not just about rhetoric
you know at a deeper level
the gender ideology movement breeds
hopelessness and depression and
self-loathing and destructiveness
it begins as a suicidal destructiveness
as Rage Against the self rejection of
the self and quickly metastasizes into
an outward rage into a desire to destroy
not only the self but to tear down the
outside world along with it
the person who's brainwashed into this
cult Who falls into this dark vortex
will be conditioned to hate her true
identity to despise her inherent nature
and then to project all of that hatred
out onto society and especially on to
those who for her sake will not play
along with the charade
those who truly care about her will be
the targets of her Wrath
that is gender ideology's built-in
defense mechanism
the hatred and violence are not side
effects they are the intended effects
this is the evil that we are up against
and evil is the point here
because you know no matter who is
responsible for the latest burst of
demonic violence
what lies at the root is the reality of
human evil and a society that Fosters
this evil
and fertilizes it
to help it grow
whether it's a trans person or anyone
else carrying out the latest mass murder
the root is always a culture in a state
of spiritual and moral Decay we have
become a country filled with numb
detached empty desensitized people with
no sense of underlying purpose and we
try to fill the gaps with things that
cannot solve the problem and will only
make it worse a lot of the time
psychiatric drugs internet entertainment
trying to numb the numbness even more
increasingly people especially young
people seeking a sense of identity and
belonging they turn to gender identity
for the answer
but there they find only more of the
confusion and despair that they're
trying to escape
this is the soil that these tragedies
grow out of it's the landscape where
everything is playing out
and it's the whole picture that we need
to see and understand
and confront
it's also the ground where many innocent
people are buried six more after
yesterday
we pray for them and their families and
and we keep fighting the evil for their
sake
now let's get to our five headlines
okay so we have some some more on the
shooting as we get into the five
headlines
um
and we'll start with this
trans terrorists massacres Christian
children
but who's the real victim
now of course the real victim according
to our satanic media are trans people
themselves they are the real victims uh
they're the ones we should be concerned
about as uh this uh media report tries
to
argue here it is
Audrey Hale Who police say identifies as
transgender that news has already
prompted some attacks against the trans
Community KPRC 2's Bryce Newberry picks
up our coverage from here
[Applause]
demonstrators at the Texas state capitol
Monday fighting against anti-trans bills
being considered by state lawmakers as
news broke that the Nashville school
shooter identifies as transgender it
doesn't excuse anything that happens I
am concerned about how opposition and
people who are anti-trans will try to
spin this concern about tweets like this
from GOP congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green writing how much hormones like
testosterone and medications for mental
illness was the transgender Nashville
school shooter taking everyone can stop
blaming guns now the comparison of they
did it because they're trans is very
unfair to trans people Andrea Segovia
from the transgender education network
of Texas joined Monday's battle at the
Capitol
fighting House Bill 1686 which would
block doctors from providing gender
transition Health Care treatment to
children now with another reason for the
Texas trans Community to be in the
spotlight and at least two months
remaining of the legislative session
Advocates worry the attacks aren't over
you can't say that because one person
did something that's a characteristic
then
be cruel to trans people and tonight
while facts about the Nashville shooting
are still surfacing the Human Rights
Campaign says trans people are much more
likely to be victims of violence rather
than perpetrators writing in a statement
regardless of the reason for this
shooting the use of violence is
reprehensible and we renew our call for
common sense gun safety legislation in
The Newsroom it's not I'm Bryce Newberry
KPRC 2 News
um
this is why I talk about the reality of
human evil and you're seeing it there
um everybody involved in in this these
are just evil people
and uh
they don't care
[Music]
um
that these people were killed they don't
and I know it's hard for us to wrap our
heads around that we can't
like how could you not care you know
there's six innocent people including
three nine-year-olds
you know to normal people like us I mean
I have two nine-year-old children and so
the the thought of
young children being slaughtered is just
it fills you with
anger and sorrow and grief and when
something like that happens that's
that's the only thing you care about
are the actual victims
and so you and I as as morally
um
you know uh as
competent normal people that's how we
feel about it you know you so you kind
of assume that everybody else must work
that way but we have to realize is that
that's not the case
you know we we live in a culture that is
uh run in many ways especially from the
institutional level by people who have
sold their souls
they've sold their souls
and so they don't they don't even have
that instinctive reaction of caring
immediately about this the first thing
they care about the first thing they
talk about and think about is uh how
this is going to impact
their preferred quote unquote supposedly
marginalized group
we make a joke about it in many other
contexts when we hear about uh when they
make some sort of Claim about Climate
Change is Gonna is gonna kill all of
humanity it's going to be an apocalypse
apocalypse in 12 years and uh you know
women and minorities most affected
and you hear that kind of thing and you
laugh about it becomes sort of a meme
but what you realize is that under the
surface it's not very funny because this
is actually how they feel
they don't care about people they care
about the ideology they care about the
narrative that's all they care they also
don't care about trans people either by
the way they don't care about trans
identified people of course they don't
if they cared about trans identified
people they would not be pushing uh this
this stuff they would be trying to help
trans-identified people to um to deal
with what is the actual source of their
Despair and all of that
so all they care about is the narrative
children are killed and uh what do we
hear trans people are are most impacted
somehow that's what we have to worry
about
you've got trans a trans terrorist
murdering Christians in school you have
as we laid out in the opening monologue
calls for further violence
and so what
but but we're not the ones as Christians
and conservatives we're not the ones who
have reason to be concerned
right it's the trans people it's the
it's the the trans activists who are
carrying out this kind of stuff they're
the ones who who we need to be worried
about
uh and also what you heard at the end
there from the Human Rights Campaign
trans people are much more likely to be
victims of violence
now if the if the insinuation there
which this is what is being insinuated
if the if the claim is that they're much
more likely to be violence if they're
more they're much more likely to be
targeted for violence because they are
trans if that's the claim then it is
totally bogus
because we hear so much about trans
people being killed genocide they're
being targeted because they're trans it
almost never happens
okay it almost never happens
there is no epidemic of it there there's
nothing like that
which is why as we've been over many
times when they when they tried to uh
support this claim of a genocide or hate
crime epidemic against trans people the
most they can ever do is just um is is
give you the number of trans people who
are homicide victims period throughout
the entire year so they'll tell you
about you know whatever it is 50 trans
people were the victims of homicide
throughout the year oh okay yeah I mean
you take any demographic group and
there's going to be homicides within
that group because we're all Mortal
human beings living in this Society
the question is how many of the
homicides were because they're trans how
many of them were targeted because of
their identity
and when you ask them that you're going
to get a lot of well girls that does
that's not the point
and if you actually look into it you
look at FBI data you're going to see you
know two three
very small handful
so there is no such epidemic
yet here we have real death and
suffering this is something that
actually happened
on this same note the uh so-called trans
resistance Network I want to read this
to you this is a a group of trans
activists
and uh this is the statement they put
out
and it appears that this statement is
real now I I couldn't independently
confirm it because uh this group has
shut down their Twitter they've locked
up their Twitter page
um and so you can't you can't go to
their Twitter page to see but this is
apparently a screenshot from their
Twitter page you can't go to their
Twitter page to confirm it because
they've locked it down
which seems to be pretty good
confirmation that it's real because if
it wasn't they would unlock the Twitter
page and tell everyone hey by the way
that thing's not real instead they've
locked it down they've gone into hiding
basically on cyberspace anyway so this
is what the uh this is what the
statement says
the trans-resisted network resistance
network has been notified the shooter
involved in today's church school
shooting in Nashville was a person
identifying as transgender known from
online profiles as Aiden or Aubry Hale
it's actually Audrey
while it is not our policy to engage
publicly with news media we believe this
moment calls for thoughtful response
from our Collective
we point out that today's incident in
Nashville Tennessee is not one tragedy
but two the first tragedy today is the
loss of life of three children and
adults we extend our deepest sympathies
and heartfelt prayers to those families
dealing with loss of loved ones there is
nothing we can offer that will Comfort
the herd or ease the sorrow we mourn
with you
the second and more complex tragedy is
that Aiden or Aubry Hale who who felt he
had no other effective way to be seen
than to lash out by taking the life of
others and by consequence himself
we do not claim to know the individual
or have access to their inner thoughts
and feelings we do know that life for
transgender people is very difficult and
made more difficult in preceding months
by a virtual Avalanche of anti-trans
legislation and public call-outs by
right-wing personalities and political
figures for nothing less than a
genocidal eradication of trans people
from society
many transgender people deal with
anxiety depression thoughts of suicide
PTSD from the near constant drumbeat of
anti-trans hate lack of acceptance from
family members and certain religious
institutions denial of our existence and
call for detransition and forced
conversion
and on and on and on I can't even keep
reading this tribe
here we have it from a group of trans
activists laid out explicitly clear that
Audrey Hale
the Demonic monster who murdered
children not to mention three adults who
are also innocent victims in this
who murdered six people is uh is one of
the victims here
because she felt bad Society made her
feel bad
well I I tell you one thing
um I don't give a damn
how this person felt okay I don't care
that her her feelings were hurt
I don't care that she was suffering I
hope she suffered
I hope she suffered a lot in her final
moments that's what I hope
that's how we're supposed to feel about
monsters who murder children
oh she felt bad good
she feels bad now burning in Hell also
I'm glad for that because it's Justice
you know here's another thought too
um
not that this is even something that we
that we need to to engage with but uh
[Music]
you know as much as we hear about how
trans people are so devastated and uh
and and you know in in such bad shape uh
you know psychologically because of uh
not being affirmed by society and all
that this is what we hear
is suffering so much uh emotionally
psychologically because I'm not being
affirmed we hear this
um meanwhile
all of our major institutions in society
are bending over backwards every second
of every day
to suck up to this group of people
affirm them make them feel good
and so maybe we should stop to consider
that first of all if you're in a
position where you need everyone in
society
to agree with you and affirm you and and
uh you know prop up your your
self-perception and all if you need
everyone
to the point where you could have all of
the major institutions constantly
celebrating you constant parades Flags
waving you're great you're special
and you can have all of that
and yet you hear a few voices saying I
don't agree with that and that like
destroys you
maybe there are some issues
some deeper issues going on
okay
maybe it's not the fault of those few
voices
who are
um who are
presenting a counter argument from
everything we hear from all the major
institutions
just a thought
meanwhile uh there's this from an NBC
reporter which has been deleted uh the
the media I mean as expected in the wake
of this thing just covering themselves
in glory
so Benjamin Ryan is an NBC reporter and
uh also an obsessed fan of mine and of
the daily wire uh he's you know he
spends much of his day tweeting about us
he's basically he's he's angling for a
job in Media Matters I think very well
qualified for Media Matters just as in
his obsession with Billy wire so this is
what he tweeted he said NBC has id'd the
Nashville school shooter as Audrey Hale
28 who identifies as transgender and had
no previous criminal record Nashville is
home to the Daily wire a hub of
anti-trans activity by Matt Walsh Ben
Shapiro and Michael Knowles
now
some people read that he deleted the
tweet and of course took no
accountability for it didn't apologize
for it uh but
many people read that as him blaming us
for the attack
and that is one way to read it and the
media was also has also been doing that
they've been blaming us blaming the
daily wire blaming conservatives because
here's the thing you know if if there's
a mass shooting
and it's someone who they can claim is
you know quote unquote on our side
someone who they can claim is quote
unquote right wing then they blame us
but if it's somebody on the other side
they still blame us
so literally no matter who commits the
mass shooting it doesn't matter it's
always our fault
and there there was uh there was quite a
bit of that including this media report
which you know attempts to
attempts to hint at it kind of offers
the hint hint wink wink nudge nudge
thing in a very unsubtle way connecting
conservatives uh to this attack let's
listen to this
that is police chief John Drake of
Nashville who is briefing reporters on
the deadly grade school shooting in
Nashville at the Covenant School there
this morning the police confirming six
dead three children one eight years old
two nine years old and three adults
including Catherine Kuntz who is the
head of the Covenant School the police
chief also said that the shooter has
been identified as 28 year old female
Audrey Hale said she's a former student
of the school and confirmed that Audrey
hill was a identified herself as a
transgender person
a state of Tennessee earlier this month
passed and the governor signed a bill
that banned transgender medical care for
minors as well as a law that prohibited
adult entertainment including male and
female impersonators after a series of
drag show controversies in that state
hmm
very unsettle hint I mean what does that
have to do with anything
um well obviously the the connection he
wants
and some people immediately being more
explicit about it but the connection
wants us to make is that somehow this
was our fault uh which going back to the
the Ben Benjamin Ryan tweet you know you
could interpret it that way saying that
well this this crime was carried out in
Nashville by the way
home to a hub of anti-trans activity by
Matt Walsh Michael those met Shapiro Ben
Shapiro by the way doesn't even live in
Nashville
um
so you could interpret the three that
way I interpret it another way uh this
one from from Benjamin Ryan anyway I
think the other way of interpreting it
is um rather than blaming us
instead sending the militants after us
you know kind of a way of uh it's
another uh hint and wink wink situation
saying oh yeah well it's a trans
terrorists shot a bunch of Christians
hey by the way
not just just down the road from from
there there are some more anti-trans
people
that to me is pretty clearly the uh the
implication
because again they don't value our lives
they think we deserve to die all of us
that's what they believe
Biden as we saw addressed the shooting
um by politicizing it but before he got
to that part of
his remarks
um it started with this and you can't
even appreciate the full uh just morbid
absurdity of this if you don't see the
video because Fox and other New Media
Outlets they cut to Joe Biden who came
to address the media and then you can
see down at the bottom of the screen the
lower third it says that uh Joe Biden is
going to address uh the the mass
shooting in Nashville
but
while it says that on the screen here's
how he actually begins his remarks
my name is Joe Biden
I'm Dr Joe Biden's husband
NIH Jenny's ice cream chocolate chip
I came down because you heard there was
chocolate chip ice cream
by the way I have a whole refrigerator
full upstairs I think I'm kidding
I mean
ah
if it were any other topic you know if
it was if it was something else we could
laugh about it just as those hyenas in
the crowd are laughing hysterically he
said he likes ice cream
but we can't even laugh about it because
this is a school shooting and he starts
off by saying I like my name's Joe Biden
and I like ice cream
and this is it's not surprising though
this is the consequence of having a
mentally deranged
uh dementia patient as president
that is what we actually have I think I
think somehow even after uh you know
three years it still hasn't totally
it I don't know I'm not sure how much it
it sinks in for people
that we actually it's not it's not a
joke it's not just something that we
laugh about
it is actually true that the president
United States
does not have his mental wits about him
and has dementia
and that is the only way to explain
how he could
come out for the media to address a
school shooting and start off literally
by saying my name is Joe Biden and I
like ice cream
we can't call that a gaff or a flub
this is just a mentally deranged old
daughtering fool who has no idea where
he is or what's going on
and not only is he in the white house
but he is actually going to run for
reelection
and might actually be elected
all right
um
we have a couple other stories that are
uh you know hitting some other some
other news items that we'll talk about
uh
briefly this is from the daily wires
it's an organization that representative
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez is a member of
has accepted sizable donations from bite
dance the Chinese parent company of the
social media platform Tick Tock which is
Democrat socialist recently defended
from a possible Nationwide ban
Jake Denton a technology policy expert
at the Heritage Foundation noted that
Acacia Cortez is a member of The
Advisory Council for the Congressional
Hispanic caucus Institute in non-profit
entity they received 115 150 000 at the
end of last year from bite dance
according to a lobbying contribution
report what a coincidence Denton said on
social media
caser Cortez recently remarked on Tick
Tock that a band of the platform of our
national security and privacy concerns
would be unprecedented and said that
such a move does not really address the
core of the issue which is the fact that
major social media companies are allowed
to collect troves of deeply personal
data about you that you do not know
about she added that the lawmaker should
instead pass a broader data privacy bill
for social media firms
so we were talking yesterday we played
some of the clip of her uh she responded
to this move to potentially ban Tick
Tock by starting her own Tick Tock
account and trying to describe why she
objects to it and she said doesn't feel
right so now we know where those those
feelings are coming from we know why it
doesn't feel right for her because uh
her organization is receiving money from
parent company of of tick tock
I mean this is the kind of this kind of
open corruption that should be
investigated and uh and of course it
won't be and even if it is nothing will
be done about it
but that's what it is and I and and by
the way
should we look at a passing a a broader
bill that has to do with data privacy
and reigning and big Tech and all the
rest of it sure we should do that
there are many of us who have been
crying out for that for years
um
but
you know big Tech should not exist in
this uh Zone in this magical like
law-free Zone where they could just do
whatever they want
and but that's the way that it's gone
for a lot of the big tech companies
um you know it extends out to the porn
industry as well
some of the the basic regulations that
any other industry any other company
would have to abide by somehow it
doesn't apply to them so yeah let's talk
about that
but there's no reason why we can't start
with this bill
which to me is clearly a good bill
and finally quickly I wanted to mention
this um
on lighter news I guess a little bit
later uh another Celebrity Divorce and
there's one line here that that's uh
that interests me actress Reese
Witherspoon just announced that she and
her husband for 12 years Jim Toth are
getting divorced the 47 year old mom of
three broke the news via her Instagram
page on Friday just days before the
couple's anniversary on Sunday
says we have some personal news share
with great deal of care consideration
we've made the difficult decision to
divorce we have enjoyed so many
wonderful years together and are moving
forward with deep love kindness and
mutual respect for everything that we
have created our biggest priority is our
son and our entire family as we navigate
this next chapter
and that's the one note that I want to
make about this we talked about the
celebrity uh justifications and excuses
for divorce last week when it was Gisele
Bundchen uh giving her reasons for
divorcing Tom Brady and it was a lot of
this self-help
self-actualization jargon about how
we'll have to you have to put I have to
discover myself I'm on a journey and I
have to discover myself and whatever it
was
um
and here it's another another common
thing that we always hear from these
people which is that uh we're getting
divorced we've made this decision
it's a mutual decision never Mutual by
the way never is mutual decision we
decided to do this we decided to embark
on this new Journey separately uh but
our top priority our top priority is our
son is is the children
well no I know that's not the case
because of your top priority was your
child you wouldn't be getting divorced
okay this is exactly what you do when
your top priority is not your child
which actually you know by the way
in a marriage
that's not even supposed to be your top
priority
okay your number one priority is
supposed to be the marriage itself
your number one priority is the marriage
because because that is that's if you
actually love your children and uh and
and uh you do prioritize their
well-being then they need the marriage
to stay intact they need the family to
stay intact
so that is largely how you prioritize
the children is by
prioritizing the marriage
um
but either way
if you if you're prioritizing your
children then you wouldn't be dissolving
the marriage because this is what they
need they need their family
you're going your separate ways are you
divorce not because you because
obviously you don't prioritize the
marriage you don't value the marriage
um and you don't prioritize your
children you prioritize yourselves and
your own individual desires and wants
and and all of that and your convenience
and your lifestyle and um
that's what you prioritize that's what
it leads to all right let's get to the
comment section
[Music]
a person says I'm sure Matt has said
this before but the gender affirming
drugs quote unquote are even worse than
just having harmful side effects the
point of them is to cause harm the point
of them is to prevent the normal healthy
physical development of a child just
think uh that needs to be said more
often you're exactly right I have made
that that point many times and uh but it
always stands repeating that we could
talk about the side effects of the drugs
we should talk about the side effects of
the drugs but
um the real issue the first and foremost
issue is the intended effects of the
drugs the intended effect as you point
out is to uh is to prevent
the
normal healthy development
of a child as you jump just restating
exactly what you said but I think you're
right
um
Mauricio says it must be torture hearing
Matt pronounce GIF so many times to
people who clearly hold the wrong
opinion yeah this one is uh there is a
wrong and a right here you know it's not
not a matter of opinion whether you say
GIF or gif
GIF stands for right it stands for
graphics interchange format okay isn't
that what it stands for
so the first word is Graphics Graphics
gif
that's it that's the end of the
conversation
I I've heard people like well the the
guy who invented the GIF he says that's
pronounced Jiff I don't know if that's
true or not but it doesn't matter
because he's wrong about it like he
might have invented this format
he didn't invent the English language in
the way that words are pronounced
Graphics
GIF that's it that's that's all there is
to it
if we got at least move on from there we
can't move on from very many
controversies in this Society but maybe
that's one at least that we can move on
from
um
ativa says so when a black person uses
the meme of Tony Stark rolling his eyes
is that white face
well of course not but that that is also
the the funny thing we talked about
yesterday the um
a digital blackface which is when a
white person uses a meme or a gif a gif
of a black person that's digital
blackface but in this article that lays
out this lengthy uh article on what was
it CNN laying all this out digital
blackness
he doesn't even acknowledge this issue
you know he he never even uh attempts to
Grapple with the question of well what
about black people use white people as
gifts and the reason he doesn't
acknowledge is because it's just it's
it's it's assumed at this point there's
no you don't even need to acknowledge it
they don't even need to say it out loud
it's we all we already know we're
supposed to already know that well
obviously uh a black person can use
Gifts of white people all they want
it's like uh the the racial double
standard is assumed at this point so
they don't feel the need to acknowledge
it or explain it it's just assume then
you're supposed to go along with that
assumption and accept that and adopt
that assumption yourself
um
Maggie May says you're so funny Matt
there's always method to Trump's Madness
it's a waste of time to even talk about
the Trump DeSantis charade
you know I I understand that Trump's
most devoted supporters that's what you
tend to believe
that um everything he does even if it
appears to be a mistake or it appears to
be a misstep or it appears to be the
wrong strategy it was always the right
strategy you know this is where that the
4D chess meme comes from
um
but but that's look that's not the case
okay for Trump it's not the case of
trump there's not always some well it
seems like this is the wrong thing it
seems like there's a bad but it's really
there's there's a plan trust the plan
right
um no no it's like it's it's that that
plan's not there it's when it appears to
be a mistake or misstep it just is
um but that's also true of anyone
that's true of of all of us like
everyone makes mistakes and missteps
okay so and it's it's so if you were to
take any random person any mortal being
who exists on Earth and insists that
everything they do is right and that
they can never make a mistake and if
there's all even if it appears to be a
mistake there's a plan behind it and
it's really this is a chess move
um that's not the case for anyone
okay because we're all flawed
uh
so
when you attempt to make Trump into some
sort of like superhero type figure
um that's always going to be a mistake
for anyone there's always going to be a
mistake for a politician to approach a
politician that way
so I'm always preaching this about
politicians that our our support I don't
want to hear anything about loyalty
okay I hate I hate the word loyalty when
applied to politicians we do not owe
them loyalty
goes the other way they owe it to us and
they have to prove themselves to us not
the other way around and our support for
politicians should always be conditional
always be conditional
it's not like I would never say that
about you know your support for your
spouse or your child that's not
conditional but we're not married to
these people
we're not in their family
so we support them because we like what
they do and if we don't like what they
do we're we are always prepared to
withdraw that support and maybe we give
the support back when they change what
they've done wrong you know that's the
way it should work
and I apply that to anyway I apply you
know even though I support Santos I
certainly applied to DeSantis
I'm perfectly willing to criticize him
in fact I did just last week
so this is how this is how we should
approach all politicians to include
um
Trump Leroy says episode 737 is our area
51 let the merch commence
I like that idea because this would be
the most obscure insular merchandise
possible that nobody
would understand even people who are
kind of uh casual fans of the show
wouldn't understand so that's why we
need that merchandise we need a t-shirt
that says something like it we just need
a t-shirt that says episode 737 does not
exist that's what we need the T-shirt to
say no context it can't even say uh the
Matt Walsh show or any anything on it
there's no other indication of what it
even refers to
and that's it we just need that on a
t-shirt
and uh maybe we'll sell five of them but
that's all right it'll be our the five
most loyal SPG members anyway
let's get to the Daily cancellation
thank you
it'll be a brief daily cancellation to
be totally honest with you
um I considered not doing this segment
at all because I try to make it a more
humorous part of the show where I can
but I'm not much in the mood for uh for
that today yet I'm not gonna let the
mood dictate how I do the show so we
turn to uh NPR and their frantic
attempts to stake out a position on the
issue of men and women's sports the
post-millennial reports quote NPR has
deleted a tweet claiming that there was
limited scientific evidence a physical
advantage of male athletes over women
athletes after backlash the statement
was in support of trans-identified males
competing in women's sports quote the
international governing body for track
and field will ban trans women athletes
from Elite women's competitions citing a
priority for fairness over inclusion
despite limited scientific evidence of
physical Advantage the now deleted tweet
read the Tweet was uh republished on
Sunday with an update quote the
international governing body for track
and field will ban trans women athletes
from Elite women's competitions citing a
priority for fairness over inclusion
despite limited scientific research
involving Elite trans athletes the
initial tweet as well as the republished
republished Tweet were hit with
Community notes in which Twitter users
noted studies on the exact subject
showing plenty of scientific evidence
that males are stronger faster and more
likely to beat women on the playing
field NPR issued a correction tweet
following the republishing of their
tweet writing quote correction an
earlier tweet incorrectly stated there
is limited scientific evidence of
physical Advantage existing research
shows that higher levels of testosterone
do impact athletic performance but
there's limited research involving Elite
trans athletes in competition
okay um
this is already incredibly embarrassing
for NPR or would be if they were capable
of embarrassment which they aren't but
even their correction is is riddled with
errors and misdirection so three points
here first
starting with the last sentence and
working our way back
we don't need research on quote trans
athletes this this is the red herring
that they use to distract from the
actual issue when they say that there's
there isn't any research or that uh when
they correct themselves and say there
isn't enough research to declare that
males have an athletic advantage over
females what they mean is that there
haven't been very many studies
specifically analyzing the performance
of trans-identified males
but that's because we don't need to
analyze trans-identified males the point
isn't how trans people perform it's how
men perform
however they identify okay whether the
man sees himself as a woman or sees
himself as a man or sees himself as a
tomato plant that is entirely beside the
point
self-perception has no impact one way or
another on the inherent physical traits
that give men a significant Edge over
women in sports
we don't need to study trans people for
this for this because uh their alleged
transness is completely and totally
irrelevant to the issue at hand
so this is like if I said um that tall
people have an advantage in basketball
and you responded that well that might
be true but we need more research before
we can determine whether a tall person
whose favorite color is blue
would also have an advantage
well no we don't need that research
because his color preference has no
bearing on this particular question
just as a man's gender identity his
perception of himself has no bearing on
the issue of men and women's sports
second yes
um as NPR was forced to acknowledge
testosterone impacts athletic
performance
but this is another misdirection
they want the entire conversation to be
focused on testosterone as if that's the
only thing that gives men an advantage
but it isn't not even close
women not only have less testosterone
but also 20 less muscle mass in their
legs smaller fast twitch muscle fiber
smaller lungs smaller Hearts weaker
bones shorter legs
um a a more limited capacity to produce
oxygen when they're exerting themselves
Etc
the advantages for men involve nearly
every part of the body it is a
physiological reality that cannot be
summed up by hormones
you can inject man a man with estrogen
but that will not even out
most of these differences
or really any of them
third even if it could
even out the differences okay which it
can't and it never will
but if it could I mean there was
something you could do to like
neutralize all of this
that wouldn't matter I still would not
support men and women's sports
and this is where the women's sports
issue threatens to derail our side the
side of sanity
because by focusing so much on the
physical differences between men and
women and the unfair advantages that men
have in sports we want that we we run
the risk of conceding that
hypothetically if these differences
could be mitigated or minimized to a
significant degree then we would
tolerate men and women's sports
but no we still wouldn't or shouldn't
because our actual argument against a
man and a woman's sport is not merely
that he's stronger and more athletic
but that he is a man
okay as always our main concern is not
preserving the Integrity of women's
sports or even any overarching issue
like fairness or privacy I mean we are
concerned with all of that but that's
not the main point the main point is
simply truth
we oppose men and women sports because
men are not women and pretending that
they are women is an assault on truth
it's also an assault on women's sports
but the far far greater concern is truth
itself so I am worried about the impact
that somebody like Leah Thomas has on
the female competitors who he stole
trophies from
I'm even more worried about the societal
impact of accepting Leah Thomas as a
woman
that is the Crux of it
and it's really the only point that
matters
why don't we want men and women sports
is it because it's unfair is it because
men have more testosterone and they have
more strength and all the rest yes yes
yes but that is all merely an offshoot
it's it's an outgrowth
of the real point which is that men are
not women
and it's as simple as that and that's
all
and that's why NPR is today canceled and
that'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block hope
to see you there if not we'll talk to
you on uh tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign